hello I'm Terry Martin good to have you
with us
these talks between Ukraine and Russia
are due to start this morning as
Russia's invasion of its neighbor enters
its fifth day the two sides are expected
to meet in Belarus near the Ukrainian
border Ukraine's President Vladimir
zelenski says he does not expect a
breakthrough but is willing to send a
delegation to try and end the war
it was calm as the sun rose over the
capitol Kiev though Ukraine said there
were sporadic pre-dawn blasts there and
in the second largest city car keep
Ukraine says it's still in control of
all major cities despite the Russian
Onslaught in many parts of the country
several residential buildings have been
hit and Ukraine says over 350 civilians
have been killed so far
weapons of war at a children's
playground in
these images uploaded to social media
purportedly show Russian soldiers the
person filming says they are shooting at
houses
but they run into Fierce resistance
a trail of Russian reconnaissance
Vehicles is left smoldering as Ukrainian
soldiers Drive the Russian army back out
of Ukraine's second largest city
the regional Governor says khakive is
back under Ukrainian control the capital
Kiev is also putting up a fight while
explosion after explosion goes off near
the Heart of the City
a war just outside the window
many flee to subway stations when they
hear Airaid sirens
it was my family I moved to our
relative's place because they are closer
to the metro station and there is a
better opportunity to run down the metro
station itself is heavy bombing take
place
in the East apartment buildings and
ruins a gas pipeline and an oil Depot in
flames
in an effort to stop the destruction
Ukraine's president agrees to peace
talks
the Ukrainian and Russian delegations
will meet without any preconditions
Frankly Speaking I do not really believe
in the outcome of the meeting
meanwhile new satellite images show a
convoy of hundreds of Russian military
vehicles approaching the capital a sign
that the fighting there may become even
more intense
let's get the very latest from DW
correspondent Pani Pacha she's in
Western Ukraine in the city of
kamenitsky finally how has the situation
developed in Ukraine overnight
not really for the better in fact there
were several attacks on the city of Kiev
on the city of harkiv these are major
cities of course this is where we have
seen the increase of a violence of
shelling over the past few days ever
since this Invasion began last week on
Thursday now it is really unclear how
it's going to continue but everyone
especially in Kiev is bracing for a
major assault as the with the amid the
the fact that there is Assurance there
by the Ukrainian president that is going
to try to negotiate that there is this a
talk possibly even this morning at the
Ukrainian a Belarusian Buddha trying to
bring about at least some sort of a
ceasefire but the situation is very
tense also here actually where we are
right now three hours West of
sirens we're blaring yes tonight so we
were really preparing to go to the
bunker again no explosions were hurt
however or no reports about that but
there are military units nearby and what
we can see actually coming to our
position here today A lot of families
packed up early this morning trying to
flee the country towards Romania while
there are there's an influx of refugees
here to hamlininsky from Kiev and many
other parts of Ukraine so the situation
is chaotic actually at this point it is
panic nervousness but also the hope that
maybe if there really is a talk today at
least some pause can be achieved
funny we're looking at uh we've seen
some satellite images showing a massive
Russian military Convoy just outside of
Kiev this Convoy is about five
kilometers long this suggests that a
major assault could be imminent as you
mentioned how is Kia preparing to defend
itself
it's incredible the way people here on
the ground try how they were trying to
unite over the course of the past few
days in fact just in front of me I see
people signing up to be drafted
voluntarily before they actually get
that phone call to go to the front line
others are again are donating blood
trying to help the way they can so if
you ask an ordinary Ukrainian they will
tell you yes we are prepared because we
are motivated of course if you look at
the numbers Russian troops versus
Ukrainian troops Russian troops are
superior compared to the Ukrainian
defense at the same time however you
also have to look at the fact that so
far at least Russia did not succeed to
occupy any major city and did not go
beyond that line in the donbass they
occupy the the self-proclaimed republics
of luhansk and Donetsk but no further
progress actually has been made other
than of course the increase of attacks
in so many parts of Ukraine
what about the humanitarian situation
there fani we're seeing reports on
social media food shortages supermarkets
with empty shelves what can you tell us
we witness that ourselves obviously we
are affected in a way in in that way too
that of course we also need to get uh
food and very basis Basics just like
anyone else and yes uh empty shelves but
there's still a basic things available
depends on which Supermarket you go to
where you actually live how many
supermarkets are open and the best
really right now is for everyone to
stock up on certain things certain items
given could be that there is a a
blackout maybe inside that means no
electricity no access to Internet so it
means people are trying to actually
without overly panicking really because
then would be even longer lines but in a
way everyone here is bracing just to be
prepared especially those who cannot go
who cannot leave across the border these
of course especially men between 18 and
60 years old who have to stay they are
not allowed to leave Ukraine but also
people who simply do not have a car or
enough gasoline to leave Ukraine and
bring their families and themselves to a
say region funny thank you very much for
now our correspondent Pani pachardar in
Western Ukraine
Ukrainian civilians have been pitching
in to resist the Russian invasion with
their lives turned upside down ordinary
ukrainians are getting involved in
collecting donations and helping to make
supplies for the Army DW correspondent
Matthias beringa met some of the
volunteers helping refugees and soldiers
in the city of Vinita Southwest of Kiev
they bring everything they can spare
clothes food money as refugees move west
and soldiers East towards the front here
in Vinita and Central Ukraine people are
organizing aid for both
Natalia who doesn't want to give her
last name leaves a youth center in
peacetime she's used to organizing
outings and summer camps now at War
she's busy directing volunteers and
sorting donations
I never imagined I'd be doing any of
this I'm learning all the time we are
improving our work every minute we are
getting there
foreign
Century Ukraine has so far been spared
heavy fighting although Airaid alarms
are frequent
but like everywhere in the country
people here have been under shock since
Russia attacked now everyone wants to
contribute a wave of solidarity is
running through Society Natalia is out
and about Around the Clock the nightly
curfew is the only time she's not on
site
I can't just sit home doing nothing and
just waiting I'm also definitely not
leaving this is our home that we love
and we're not going anywhere
it's not only about donating Goods many
also contribute their time making
camouflage nets for the army green and
brown clothes are separated from the
donations and cut into pieces the rest
is a lot of Handy work
the Ukrainian Army has been at War for
eight years still lacking many basic
items including protective equipment
and many here have somebody at the front
a husband brother sister or in Natalia's
case a 19 year old son
we are in touch I can talk to him once a
day it's those few minutes that I'm
waiting for all day
being active is also a way for many here
to deal with their worries
Russian President Vladimir Putin has put
his country's deterrence forces
including its nuclear weapons system on
high alert in a video from the Kremlin
Putin said NATO Powers had made
aggressive statements towards Russia he
also pointed to economic sanctions that
will cut off Russian Banks from
International transactions
not only are Western countries taking
unfriendly economic steps against our
country
I mean the illegal sanctions that
everyone knows about very well
but the top officials of leading NATO
countries are also making aggressive
statements about our country
therefore I order the minister of
defense and the chief of the general
staff
to put the deterrent forces of the
Russian military
to a special mode of combat Duty
beautiful
let's bring in Thomas V Gold here he's a
journalist and Military expert thanks
for being with us uh President Putin has
put his country's deterrence forces and
I understand this includes its nuclear
weapons system on high alert what do you
make of this
well first of all you would expect that
any nuclear country may be the U.S
France United Kingdom and Russia would
have the deterrence forces on alert any
time so this is more or less at this
point in time a psychological operation
it's a threat an unveiled threat against
the West because if you see the
situation on the ground in Ukraine there
is no military justification for
thinking about use of nuclear forces so
this means this is to deter the West to
to give a threat to Nato and the U.S and
so far the U.S have said we have no
reason to change our defense conditions
we'll stay as we are which I think is
the only way to react to this for weeks
we've been hearing that Russia's Army is
far superior to that of Ukraine but but
they haven't progressed as far as many
had expected in Ukraine how do you
explain that
well many in the west or all in the west
have been surprised by this they're a
different maybe different reasons for
this one is what the Pentagon last night
called the creative resistance of the
ukrainians who are dealing with Russian
forces well counter to their Doctrine
their ambushing they are attacking
support convoys all these things on the
other hand as we've seen in the videos
from the front lines it's not the newest
Russian material it's not the nearest
tanks and all this stuff which has been
brought up so either Russia is not as
well equipped as everybody in the west
thought over the recent years or Russia
is keeping its most modern its best
equipped troops still back and will
bring them into the fight later
I want to ask you about the steps that
uh the EU has taken uh EU members on
Sunday took significant steps to prop up
Ukraine's military uh what difference
will this make
well there is a potential for for indeed
making a big difference we've seen
mostly anti-tank weapons anti-tank
guided missiles Stinger Man pads men
portable air defense systems and all
this which is to be distributed widely
which doesn't need a long time Education
and Training but on the other hand last
night Joseph Borel the EU foreign policy
ahead said you would also bring in
fighter planes I haven't seen a
confirmation for this yet but this would
mean a significant difference because
Ukrainian air defense strange enough is
still working there is no Russian air
superiorities so far that's also a
surprise for most western expert because
everybody expected that Russia would
take over over the Skies over Ukraine
within a day right
Now The Economist news outlet has
suggested that the sanctions imposed on
Russia particularly on the Central Bank
are so crippling that the Kremlin might
interpret them as an act of War do these
sanctions have any military significance
in your view
well
normally I would say no but if you see
the kremlin's point of view they might
well interpret this as an act of war and
this was all would also partially
explain the the nuclear threat
we don't really know whether the Kremlin
says what's happening to our banks to
our economy is the same as a military
attack and we will react accordingly so
that's still open to interpretation
okay journalist and Military expert
Thomas beagle there thank you so much
for now
you're welcome
turning point in Europe's history that's
how German Chancellor Olaf Schultz
described Russia's war against Ukraine
speaking to a special session of
parliament on Sunday
Schultz announced a raft of policy
changes that would have been Unthinkable
just days ago Germany will spend
billions beefing up its military now and
reduce its dependence on Russian energy
Choice
German Chancellor Olaf Schultz is moving
the country away from his traditional
pacifist defense and security policy to
a tougher more direct one
Shackled by its first and second world
war history Germany has been hesitant to
involve itself in Conflict but Schultz
says this is a new era
this wall is a catastrophe for Ukraine
but this war will also turn out to be a
catastrophe for Russia
Russia has done the unthinkable bringing
the most aggressive military assault to
Europe since World War II at the special
session of the mundistag Schultz
announced Germany is sending 1 000
anti-tank weapons and 500 surface-to-air
missiles directly to Ukraine instead of
using a third party it will also invest
100 billion euros in a special military
fund and after years of pushing against
calls from the U.S to invest more in
NATO Schultz announced that's happening
too
hiking National defense spending to more
than two percent of Germany's economic
output per year
President Putin President Putin should
not underestimate our determination to
defend every square meter of our
alliance's territory together with our
allies
Mr schneiden we are cutting off Russian
Banks and state companies from financing
we are preventing the export of future
technology to Russia we are focusing on
the oligarchs and their Assets in the EU
Germany and its allies hope these tough
multilateral sanctions will force Russia
to retreat and bring peace back to
Ukraine
joined Now by our chief political
correspondent Melinda crane Melinda you
were following this all along over the
weekend a major turnaround in German
foreign and security policy walk us
through this what changes are we looking
at well first of all concretely we're
going to see Germany uh break with the
long-standing prohibition on sending
weapons to a conflict zone so a very
direct support now for Ukraine secondly
harsh economic sanctions on Russia not
only the exclusion of some Russian Banks
from that Swift payment transfer
information system but also freezing the
reserves of the Russian Central Bank a
very big move indeed and thirdly a
massive increase in defense spending
something you and I have talked about
for years but that always looked like it
was somewhere out there in the realm of
uh hope it wasn't going to happen
underlying all of that and this is the
most important thing is indeed a
tectonic shift in perspective away from
essentially a post-world War II and
post-cold War consensus that saw Germany
tie its own hands militarily absolutely
prioritize diplomacy and dialogue see
itself as surrounded by friends after
1989 with the idea that maintaining good
commercial relations with everybody
would ensure stability and moderation
and there's clear recognition now the
chancellor said it we live in a new
world and we must defend our democracy
if we want to preserve it
now Germany is going to ramp up its
military capabilities in a way that we
have never seen before in the post-war
period a hundred billion going in as a
special fund for the bundes fair more
than two percent spending uh on uh GDP
spending on the military moving forward
annual spending Melinda ramping up
military capabilities is a slow process
what kind of time frame are we talking
about here and is it can it make any
difference to the current conflict well
a hundred billion is double the current
defense budget so we're looking at a
massive increase just within this fiscal
year that will begin to remedy some of
the gaps and deficits in the bundesver
and the chancellor talked about gaps and
deficits basically in all areas Hardware
skills and capabilities technology
meaning cyber uh Logistics
airplanes uh boats you name it basically
every everything and that reflects the
fact that Germany essentially is an
economic giant but a military [ __ ] so
no that's not going to happen overnight
and he absolutely acknowledged that and
said that's why we will now be investing
more than two percent two percent is the
NATO Target two percent of GDP on
defense spending he said we will now be
doing more than that currently it's 1.5
percent yeah yeah way below been
promising to do it for years and years
since 2014 every year Germany makes this
promise it looks like no it actually
might happen suddenly overnight I mean
it's it's quite a quite a turnaround uh
there is a strong pacifist streak in
Germany uh which is understandable in
light of the second world war and the
first world war for that matter so
is that a particular this is
particularly true on the left the left
is well represented in the current
government is Germany jumping over its
shadow now is it putting its pacifist
streak behind it yes in fact that's why
I said I think we're seeing a break with
the post-world War II consensus a break
with German thinking that's gone on for
nearly 80 years the idea being that in
some ways Germany learned the lessons of
World War II too well as you know that
was a war of aggression instigated by
Germany itself and coming out of that
there was a sense that
military is not a tool of policy in
other words klausovitz famous dictum
that military uh is a continuation of
foreign policy by other means that was
not a part of the German thinking and we
have seen a change within the green
party as well as you say junior
Coalition partner but they were the ones
pushing this Chancellor very hard to uh
to go further on weapons exports to go
further are on Vigilant defense spending
so I think now we're seeing also the
social Democrats who also have that
pacifist tradition finally getting in
touch with another side of their history
and their Roots namely helmet Schmidt
stationing of the pershings that was
deterrence that was not diplomacy that
was not ostpolitic and I think now
perhaps we're seeing a very real shift
on the left
not everybody is happy about this I was
at I was downtown yesterday during the
demonstration seeing a lot of placards
that were also saying you know no
rearmament uh in Germany during the
bonus talk session when these huge
investments in the bonus bar were
announced we saw particularly members of
the left party not applauding for these
how much support is there within the
population and in within the German
political establishment for these uh the
boosting of the Germany's military so
the left party as you say cat calls
booze uh real a lot of noise during that
special session of the bundestag
yesterday on the streets my impression
is that the wake-up call definitely has
been heard but that this is a very
wrenching moment for many Germans and uh
you could hear that in the speeches made
yesterday by in fact all of the leaders
saying we know people are sitting around
their kitchen tables this is what the
chancellor said grandparents are saying
wait a minute we thought war in Europe
can't happen again what is going on and
a clear recognition on the part
especially of Chancellor Schultz that he
needs to lead people on this journey
it's going to be a hard journey for many
many Germans and it's uh this comes of
course after tremendous pressure from
Germany's allies particularly within
NATO to uh to finally step up to the
plate as it were in boosting Germany's
military capabilities Melinda crane our
chief political correspondent thank you
so much
now hundreds of thousands of people have
protested against the Russian invasion
in cities around the world here in
Berlin a huge rally took place at the
Landmark Brandenburg gate there were big
demonstrations also in Paris Madrid and
a string of other capitals people have
been attempting to protest in dozens of
Russian cities as well but they've been
met by a police Crackdown a monitoring
group says at least 2 000 people were
detained standing up against Vladimir
Putin's War
they were chanting no to war in Russia
from Saint Petersburg to Siberia
protesting their country's invasion of
Ukraine
and in so many places
the script was the same
inspired chance followed by action from
security forces
often in riot gear
[Music]
can't be any worse were the aggressor
State and people are dying because of us
I'm ashamed I haven't been able to live
normally for several days
I'm burning with shame
ukrainians well away from Russia were
meanwhile burning with pride their
national anthem played outside the
Russian Embassy in Berlin
and over at the Brandenburg Gate Police
left more than 100 000 people to chide
Vladimir Putin and support ukrainians
it is our backyard they are our
neighbors our brothers our cousins or
co-workers
my country which is Ukraine is killing
people killing children I wish I could
do more but coming here and showing our
solidarity showing that we really want
the people of Ukraine to be safe the
attack on Ukraine is an attack on us and
all our ideas just like the ukrainians
have been telling us for the past eight
years
[Music]
the port for Ukraine was also found in
cities as varied as Paris
erbil in Kurdish Iraq
Santiago Chile
[Applause]
and the Lithuanian Capital Vilnius where
ex-pat belarusians protested their
country's support for The Invasion also
without police interference
but back inside Russia in yakatarinburg
east of the Ural Mountains the voices of
protest
quickly muffled
well they'll have people around the
world protest Putin's war against
Ukraine many in Russia of course are
backing the president Russian media have
repeated Putin's claim that the
so-called military special military
operation was a reaction to Ukrainian
aggression those who attempt to protest
as we saw are quickly silenced
a protest that isn't technically allowed
to be one will therefore be broken up
here in Moscow a heavy police presence
means that many don't even dare to
protest out of fear of arrest
you don't agree with what's happening
we're in shock we don't know how to
express this because no one listens to
us we're being persecuted and beaten
we're afraid to go out on the street
because we're immediately detained every
word we say is met with hostility we
simply don't get a chance to join a
legal protest
I didn't even try I've seen how quickly
people were detained when they came out
with anything there's
protesters gathered in around 50 Russian
cities on Sunday the demonstrations were
particularly large here in Saint
Petersburg across the country 2500
protesters were detained according to
human rights groups
but many Russians support their
government state TV propaganda denies
that there is fighting in Kiev there's
not a word about civilian casualties or
attacks on civilian targets it's not a
war at all
people here are collecting aid supplies
but solely for the civilians evacuated
to Russia from the separatist regions
many are convinced that their tanks are
riding to the rescue
it's not a wall it's a special military
operation against Nazis who have seized
power in Ukraine
but the Ukrainian president is Jewish
how can he also be a Nazi we live in
surprising times
of course I support our Putin
just a special military operation
backing for their president for many
Russians
while those who oppose him face ending
up behind bars
well peace talks between Ukraine and
Russia are due to start this morning as
Russia's invasion of its neighbors
enters its fifth day the two sides are
expected to meet in Belarus near the
Ukrainian border Ukraine's President
Vladimir zielinski says he doesn't
expect a breakthrough but he's willing
to send a delegation to try and end the
war
it was calm as the sun rose over the
capital kieval though Ukraine said there
were sporadic pre-dawn blasts there and
in the second largest city khaki Ukraine
says it's still in control of all major
cities despite the Russian Onslaught in
many parts of the country several
residential buildings have been hit and
Ukraine says over 350 civilians have
been killed so far
you are watching special coverage of the
war in Ukraine here on dwtv I'm Terry
Martin
the Russian Ruble has plunged to a
record low dropping more than 30 percent
against the U.S dollar this comes after
the U.S and Europe imposed sanctions
aimed at cutting the country off from
the Global Financial system long queues
of Russians scrambling to withdraw money
from cash machines could be seen across
the country in an attempt to prop up the
ruble Russia's Central Bank doubled its
key interest rate to an unprecedented 20
percent in order domestic export
companies to sell foreign Reserves
the International Community is Raising
its voice against Russia over its
invasion of Ukraine the United Nations
security councils called a rare
emergency meeting of the 193-member
general assembly due to take place today
11 of the council's 15 members voted in
favor of the rush of the resolution
Russia voted against the move while
China India and the United Arab Emirates
abstained Russia was unable to use its
veto to block the resolution since the
boat was procedural U.S and its allies
at the UN say Russia is becoming
isolated internationally it is called
for an emergency
European Union has decided to finance
the purchase and delivery of weapons and
equipment to Ukraine it's the first time
the EU is sending weapons to a country
under attack European commissioner
president Ursula funder Alliance says
the block is also closing its airspace
to Russian aircraft and will ban
state-owned media channels Russia Today
and Sputnik she also announced new
sanctions targeting the regime of
Belarusian leader Alexander lukashenko
for supporting Russia's invasion
here's how Funderland explained the
significance of these developments
as the war in Ukraine rages on and
ukrainians fight bravely for their
country European Union steps up once
more its support for Ukraine and the
sanctions against the aggression
aggressor that is Putin's Russia
for the first time ever the European
Union will finance the purchase and
delivery of weapons and other equipment
to a country that is under attack
this is a watershed moment
with more let's bring in our
correspondent Christina mundoa in
Brussels Christine tell us more about
how the EU is moving on Ukraine what do
these latest steps mean
well Terry the the significance of of
this announcement by the European Union
to collectively purchase uh military uh
Weaponry lethal Weaponry for the
Ukrainian Armed Forces cannot be
understated as usual if underlying
they're the EU commission president said
it is a watershed moment it's never
happened in the European Union's history
in the weeks leading up to this Invasion
we have seen individual member states
from the European Union making military
contributions to the Ukrainian Armed
Forces but this was bilateral and was no
means coordinated at an EU level in fact
many people did not expect when we heard
the news yesterday that this was
actually going to happen people thought
assumed many people analysts thought the
European Union was going to continue to
encourage individual member states to
support the Ukrainian Armed Forces but
to take this collective decision was
really really significant so they're
going to be using an instrument that
they created called the European peace
facility and we understand that money uh
to the tune of about 450 million euros
has been set aside to purchase things
like lethal ammunition air defense
systems anti-tank systems that are then
going to be given to the Ukrainian Armed
Forces uh this EPF this European peace
facility this instrument was set up last
year it has been in use for example
supplying the African Union uh with with
assistance but not lethal assistance not
the kind of ammunition that the
Ukrainian Armed Forces will be getting
so certainly very significant and is
expected to bolster the Ukrainian Armed
Forces as they continue to battle the
Russians on the ground
so something of a watershed moment here
for European security and foreign policy
as well now Ukraine is aspiring to join
the European Union that's part of what
all this conflict is about assuming that
Ukraine retains its independence
Christine what are its prospects of
actually becoming an EU member state
well in in in in the days
um after the The Invasion began uh some
EU member states
opened up that conversation they they
made public remarks expressing that
Ukraine should be granted a path to
accession into the European Union Poland
for example Slovakia for example the
Polish president just this weekend also
this weekend we heard from the
commission president Oz live Wonderland
she said and I quote they are one of us
referring to Ukraine and we want them in
of course she she put a caveat to that
to say down the line
um you might know Terry that in 2008 the
ukrainians did apply for EU membership
that application was unsuccessful for a
number of reasons as quoted by the
European Union they cited the corruption
and the need for other reforms there are
some countries already in talks with the
European Union right now Ukraine is not
even in talks but it's Parliament took
the decision in 2017 to adopt a law that
made EU membership part of its strategic
foreign policy and security policy it
doesn't appear at the momentary that
there are more EU member states who have
expressed that keenness that desire to
bring Ukraine into the fold of course
there would be implications for the
European Union for example if Ukraine
were to have been a a European Union
member now much more would have been
needed in terms of perhaps boots on the
ground in support of the Ukrainian Armed
Forces so it does appear that the
majority of member states are reserved
about that they've at least not made
public remarks the kind that we've heard
from from the Polish uh
president as well as the Slovakian head
of state
so you say the majority of EU member
states are reserved about this uh so is
this crisis in Ukraine regarding Ukraine
bringing the EU closer together or is it
another source of division
Terry the the unitedness if I can call
it that that we've seen in the European
Union on on this on on coming to
Ukraine's defense on on condemning uh
Russia
um has been something that a lot of
people have been taken by surprise in
fact some analysts have gone as far as
to say that even Vladimir Putin in the
Kremlin didn't budget for that level of
coordination and unity among the
European Union member states uh it was
Collective condemnation of Russia's
actions from the very get-go Collective
decisiveness in terms of the reaction
that we've seen uh in the in in the
aftermath of this Invasion there have
been meeting after meeting here in
Brussels a foreign
foreign ministers and and the heads of
state some of those meetings virtuals
meetings with with allies in Washington
the NATO partnership as well and we've
really seen what many call unprecedented
unity and even for some member states
that have certain issues in the European
Union who are known to pay perhaps lean
towards Russia even these have come into
the fold not only condemning Russia but
expressing the importance of the
European Union countries like like
Hungary the the Hungarian prime minister
Victor Orban coming out and saying that
we need to preserve the European Union
that this is our future
and so these are very unprecedented
times that it really has brought the
block together in a way that many uh
have have been taken by by surprise by
Terry
Christine thank you very much our
correspondent Christine munwa there in
Brussels